the Joe Rogan experience there is the
Fonz
oh you jet skied over the shark yeah
this is what it does he's popping up you
ski in the lake or somebody that Oh got
a leather jacket yeah I think it's more
unbelievable that he'd wear a leather
jacket waterskiing then jump over a
bunch of sharks
well how about he's got it in between
his legs look look how he's doing that
go back to that original picture that
one you just had to figure - yeah but
that's black and white that's too artsy
right there look it he's got it in
between his legs that's the pole wait
that looks like he's really doing that -
I bet he is Wow don't work Henry I mean
they didn't have CGI back then he kind
of had to do it right yeah up until the
point where it actually like flew
through the air and then they got some
rugged Brad Pitt from once upon a time
in Hollywood type dude it's jumped at
that moment has not jumped the shark as
me and stuff yeah but it's crazy that it
was such a bad episode mm-hmm that it
became like symbolic of a show going off
the rails yeah so jump the shark I like
a good two season show mm I love I love
a miniseries I love things that end to
watch Mazal know I wanted a little bit
of it here's my family I don't think the
jokes are funny mm well it's contextual
yeah and I get that but it's like I
don't know I just have a hard time bull
rider listen I've been watching a lot of
Lenny Bruce over the last few months I
found this one Lenny Bruce channel on
YouTube it's got all of his old old
clips from various television
performances and they don't make me
laugh you know I know he's the best I
mean it means yeah I mean I won't say
he's the best but he's the Godfather of
this thing that we do the you and I both
do right he's the guy that started he
really is the guy who who started
talking about [ __ ] instead of just
telling jokes he started like talking
about social problem
why is this and relationships and
sadness and all kinds of weird stuff I
mean he developed a whole different kind
of style of stand-up comedy but it's not
funny because you're looking at
something that happened in 1950 in 1960
it's just it's so hard for it to
translate comedy unlike anything else
loses its that
they give you and listen to like some
even like Redd Foxx or something like
really great old stand-up it's not that
good I don't know though I I do think
there are some jokes that stand up sure
sure I think there's some people that do
it that like even you know fifty years
from now people will look back and be
like that jokes still funny oh yeah well
he had some of those Lenny Bruce had one
joke that many comics have accidentally
told since then mm-hmm because they
didn't know any better but it was about
gay people that being gay is against the
law is a key it's a kin slaw dig so they
put you in jail with a bunch of guys
want to have sex with you right it was
great yeah back then it murdered I mean
back then it was just a [ __ ] nuclear
bomb no I go [ __ ] that's what you can
imagine being in the audience and
hearing someone talk like that for the
first time oh yeah
like cuz like the best comedy I think is
things you you didn't like as soon as
someone says it you're like I have
always thought that yes you know they're
just like vocalizing something you were
never able to kind of put together yes
and that had to be that yeah in that
audience then be like yeah people were
so suppressed then I mean that's the
other thing about Lenny Bruce he went to
jail multiple times I mean he was
arrested multiple times for telling
jokes
yeah just like just kept doing it didn't
give up didn't safe well this is
obviously not smart right he kept Dylan
I kept pushing the envelope George
Carlin same thing he went to jail for it
- that's real stand-ups though you know
like you know real stand-up ones that
are just like no I have to do this yeah
if you don't do it for like a week and
people and you're just like crawling out
of your skin also the audience
is ultimately supposed to be the judge
of whether or not something's good and
if that's not the case then we're losing
personal freedom
we're not asking someone to like you
know you know like someone's not going
onstage and saying you know I'm going to
advocate that you murder someone here's
their address we're all gonna do it
together let's meet up we're not talking
about that right we're talking about
someone cracking a joke and the audience
laughs and they enjoy it and today even
today when people get upset about
someone stand-ups at and they try to
cancel something and listen to the
audience right was was the audience
laughing well they know it's a joke
right they're at a comedy show so they
know it's a joke and they were laughing
why do you have a problem with it you're
not even there so you have a problems
look at women in Saudi Arabia you got
against a you [ __ ] cowards yeah again
it's hard yeah it's easy like I hate
anytime like I I'm in favor of a comic
telling whatever jokes they want and
then like the only way you're gonna know
it's funny is if you say it out loud to
an audience yes and it might not be
funny the first thousand times you say
it until you figure it out well that was
my giant issue with comics that were
going after Louie after that set was
leaked the only thing people should have
been mad about that is that the set was
leaked yeah that should be that should
have been like you don't know where he's
gonna end up with that he's known for
doing huge premises that you disagree
with
and then he convinces you why he's right
in a very funny way and tongue-in-cheek
yeah - I mean it's not like he really
thinks that someone pushed a fat kid in
front of a bullet and that's why they're
talking in front of CNN he's he'll
figure out a way to make that work this
is his first time doing stand-up in ten
months yeah like let let's see where the
joke goes but you know that and I know
that because that's what we do but
there's a lot of people that don't even
understand the mechanics of creating a
joke that right like a lot of times
you'll go up and you'll have a premise
and like kind of [ __ ] know there's
something that he might eat [ __ ] with
that joke for a couple of months before
it really starts really starts catching
years maybe even you know like there's a
there's always jokes I've had that like
now I'm coming back to because I was
like I wasn't ready to tell it then and
now I'm getting back to it I'm like okay
maybe this direction
yeah like it's especially the harder the
premise like it's kind of take a while
people have no idea how hard it is to
write jokes well that's our ease entire
new hour he's doing you know his whole
new hour is called jus and it's all you
know he grew up Orthodox Jewish like in
you know he had to go to Israel and take
religious classes all day studying the
Talmud [ __ ] 1012 hours a day
like he was doing the whole deal and his
whole hour now is about this and we had
talked about him doing bits about that
years and years ago but he's like I
wasn't ready cuz I my stand-up wasn't
good enough yet I didn't understand how
to craft a joke yet yeah and it I mean
it takes a while to get there and
especially stuff that's personal like
that to you and like you want to do it
justice you only get to tell that story
once onstage and then once you do those
jokes
hopefully they were good enough cuz
you're really not gonna get to revisit
them yeah for you to go back over you're
like hey I put an album out 10 years ago
and it kind of sucks so I'm gonna redo
all those bits yeah please don't go back
and listen to the week after you see the
second version
[Applause]